well I I guess it's just tradition Big
Finish time and the one that my patreon
supporters opted to have me do for this
go is the Holy Terror which is a Sixth
Doctor audio adventure so this will be
my first one dealing with the six doctor
only because the first one I did was
silence of time which featured three
doctors including the sixth so this is
my first time dealing with him on his
own in Big Finish
and so I was a little bit nervous about
that although also excited because yeah
I even just a little bit I got of him
but not a little bit but about a third
on the whole story that I got of him in
sirens of time I already liked Colin
Baker in the audio as a heck of a lot
more than I liked him the TV show so I
was excited for that I was excited
because this featured Frobisher who was
a character I had heard a ton about but
haven't read any of the comics or heard
any of the audios that the character has
appeared in and it's also written by Rob
Sherman who is a name that I mainly know
I mean I've only ever experienced Rob
Sherman's writing one other time and
that is because he wrote the series one
episode dalek which is in fact an
adaptation of his own earlier audio
drama called Jubilee which I'll get to
eventually but for right now so band and
DA like it brilliant it's a great
episode it's phenomenal so that's my
only direct knowledge of it but I also
know that he is the favorite writer of
one of my favorite youtubers which is
Stu bagful
and he's raved about Rob Sherman more
than a few times and I'm not gonna say
that automatically made it be like oh I
bet this is brilliant because Stu
bankfull and I don't always line up in
terms of our thoughts I mean like he
really likes the Waldo moment as an
episode of black mare for some reason
but I knowing what it is that he tends
to like I was really curious to see what
I was going to get
with this and it is it is something else
this episode it's I I'm gonna do what I
usually do I'm gonna hold off on
spoilers till a little bit later I'll
give you a heads up before I get there
but there's a lot to talk about this and
a lot of the most fascinating stuff to
talk about I can't until the spoiler
section so let's go broad strokes it's
amazing like I'm honestly I'm kind of
blown away by this now I'm not going to
go so far as to say that it's better
than spare parts but for me and what I
like and how it connected with me I like
this better than spare parts I love this
spare parts I thought spare parts was
phenomenal but hearing this there's part
of me that's like how is this why is
everyone like oh if you're gonna listen
to any Big Finish you know be sure you
you listen to spare parts or you know
you check out this you know compilation
thing your is my dad Ross and but I
don't I don't see that I haven't seen
the Holy Terror come up in those
conversations and wow wow I was really
blown away by this okay as much of the
plot as I can lay out before it gets
into spoilers so the doctor and
Frobisher and if you don't know who
Frobisher is oh boy
how do we explain this okay so Frobisher
is a shapeshifter and his his preferred
most common and how he appears in this
story form that he takes is that of a
talking penguin and he talks with a kind
of a Brooklyn accent because he's a
private investigator so I said that's
the companion is a talking penguin
so that's Frobisher so the doctor in
Frobisher basically the the TARDIS kind
of gets fed up and
as the doctors says it goes on strike
and parks were it feels like parking
with absolutely no input even we're not
even taking the doctor's request and the
doctor and Frobisher end up in this
castle and this castles pretty expansive
it's pretty big but if they land
basically in the middle of a power
transition the god emperor who is
worshipped as a god and treated as a God
by the by the populace and and all the
the servants the slaves who live here
has died and so we're going through the
standard ceremony of appointing his
successor which is of course his son and
everything involved in that and we owe
it it opens on this with the scry like
the the official scribe the one who you
know writes down everything that's going
on basically keeping keeping up the
Bible like the Bible gets updated in
real time every time their God dies and
a new one gets appointed because the
thing is they take this the Emperor's
got thing really literally so what that
means is whenever the Emperor dies that
proved that he was not in he was in fact
not a god therefore they have to tear
down all of his statues his his wife
because he gets killed as a heretic and
the thing is everyone's really just
reserved like accepting about this like
yeah this is this is the way it is like
the we have described he gets jailed for
being a heretic
and they ask him you know who do you
worship and he says I worship offended I
don't think it's the same the nuts like
Pippin the fifth and and they're all
he's dead that is heresy you must you we
must now kill you unless you renounce
and say that you believe in him in the
sixth and he's like oh well yes I I do
that Oh
in the interior hello that's all right
then my gonna take some get more of
these you know your way out right it's
just so routine at this point this
entire process and honestly that opening
that opening reeks of Monty Python it is
it is the Spanish Inquisition level of
absurdity it's amazing and here's but
here's what is really stunning about
this story because I mean the dr.
Frobisher they land in the middle of
this and obviously this is insanity
that's going on man you know things just
play out from there but what's brilliant
about this story cuz I I know very
little about most of these big finished
stories before I listen to them and
that's by intent I really want to come
in cold and be surprised by them so what
amazed me is that I I got worried early
on I'm like okay this is this is funny
this is absurdist this is pointed I got
worried is this gonna become an overly
snarky just punch down at religion and
religious beliefs and faith because
regardless of my own feelings about
faith I know I wasn't raised in a
religious household but so regardless of
my own feelings about it I whenever I
see people like pick at it for humor it
can usually come across really
condescending really mean-spirited it's
a big part of why I can't stand Ricky
Gervais I really can't stand him and and
as much as I love him some of George
Carlin's stuff towards the end of his
life rubbed me the wrong way for that
same reason again it's not because it's
attacking beliefs I actually have it's
just because there's nothing but
meanness or or a sense of superiority
behind it and I was really worried that
I was gonna get that here because I felt
like the setup had the
potential to go in that direction but
not only did it first of all open with
the smart kind of you know making video
picking out religion which things like
say you know Monty Python's life Brian
does so brilliantly which is to rather
than attack the concept of faith attack
the practices of it so it's not saying
religion is bad it's saying look at the
craziness that we allow to go on in the
name of that so it's very carefully
targeted it's not Minoo it's well bound
so it opens well balanced in that way
but then ultimately as the story unfolds
and I can't really say what it turns
into but it's ultimately it's not about
religion it uses the filter of religion
to talk about rituals the point of them
the use of them the danger of them the
absurdity of them and it does that
through the filter of these religion
yeah it's slightly political but mostly
religious rituals that this society is
going through but it's not that that's
the trappings that's not what it's
really about and when I say that it kind
of becomes about something else I also
don't want to sell it wrong this is it's
not like a huge twist it's not like in
really throws you for a loop you know
but gradually as the story goes on what
it where it ends up by the end is
absolutely not anywhere that I would
have thought it would have gone based
off the starting set up and and the
opening premise and the first quarter or
so of this story and and and it's a
gradual shift so it's not like a an you
know hard gear shift and now we're doing
this it's like it's like about uh about
twenty minutes into things having
started to shift I look back and go oh
this isn't where we started at all and
it brings in and I get like when I said
I like this better than spare parts I I
really need to underline the word I me
because it hits so many things that I
personally love and really enjoy seeing
explore
or in fiction pretty much enough which I
can get into until I get into spoilers
so what else do I want to talk about
before I get to spoilers well let's talk
about the dr. Colin Baker he's very good
as the dog and it's funny because his
direct involvement in the plot is fairly
peripheral for most of it and there have
been times that that's been a problem
for me I hate it when it feels like the
story would have resolved without the
doctor thankfully that's not the case
here he is often background or sidelined
during the proceedings of what's going
on but he is ultimately very important
in terms of resolving everything at the
end yeah at the same time doesn't feel
like he just swept in and fixed
everything for everybody but he is sort
of like nudging things to where they
need to get so he that works in terms of
his level of involvement and it also
helps that the supporting cat the cast
of characters this society is really
compelling and on a lot of different
levels and again in a way that shifts
because it starts out so funny in its
absurdity and then it gets a little bit
dark as you realize the degree to which
all of this goes and gets taken and then
it gets really unsettling at points and
you discover you know new layers of
depth new meaning just as the story
progresses and and you know through
these characters besides the doctor now
phurba sure who I mentioned I enjoyed
him I'd liked him he wouldn't even make
my top five characters from this from
this episode though he wouldn't I mean
the doctor would still make the top five
but like before I would bring up
Frobisher I bring up Eugene the scribe
who's this incredibly endearing old man
who was just you know he's not a part of
the story but he's constantly trying to
keep track of it and also embellishing
it you know to make it sound a little
bit better you know because every
coronation that has to be a miracle and
usually it's literally a magic trick
it's literally like a card trick or
whatever but when he copies it down it's
a volcano
it's an earthquake you know things like
that so he's great I love him a lot
there's children who's in kind of and
he's a take on Richard the third
basically he's the twisted half-brother
of the of the guy who's the who's the
rightful successor and things that are
done with him are really interesting the
the mother of of the new God Emperor she
is fascinating to me like that every
time she talked I'm like I could just
pick at this forever and just it's so
enjoy what I'm getting what I'm
uncovering there's a high priest
character that takes some really
interesting turns like this is just it's
an astonishing cast and all really well
performed and I part of me really
worries that I'm over selling this but
again I'm just gonna emphasize this was
amazing to me I don't know if everyone's
inclinations for what they like I'm
stories are gonna line up with mine so
that you will get the same experience I
had with this but for me this was
astounding and now I'm gonna start
getting into spoilers so I can talk more
specifics about why so spoilers in three
two one
so ultimately it becomes a story about
relationships between parents and
children the things that don't work the
damage when things go wrong the degree
to which children can't understand
what's going on with their parents yet
continue to have faith and hope in them
and the way that we run away from the
horrible things we've done the way that
rituals can be used as a way to distract
us from the things that we don't want to
have to deal with the way that rituals
can at the same time be very comforting
and can give us something meaningful the
the the meta levels of this thing as it
as it goes on and you and you realize
that this is a story that is effectively
being written in it
it is a story it's a deliberate
narrative within the the audio drum
itself and Eugene being you know the guy
who's written everything down and has
effectively created this world even
though he doesn't understand that that's
his place in all this and you realize
all these characters who were at one
point the doctor says to the high priest
you're a stereotype and he's not even
saying that as a put-down like yeah you
know what's wrong with you or it's
insulting him he's being honest he's
telling him like you were written by a
guy who doesn't have the creativity to
give you depth you are a stereotype that
is all you can ever be and then to have
the high priest like try so hard to defy
his own nature and be like I'm going to
die I can't escape it I will have a
noble death and it doesn't work and he
breaks down and he he becomes the
sniffling backstabbing thing that is his
nature cuz that's what always happens
because he wasn't granted the depth of
character by his creator to ever
possibly be more than that and yet
you've got some characters where there's
hints that there is a little bit more
than that the the mother I I mentioned
she man she's she is so cruel and she
revels in it but she's so tired of
everything she is exhausted by it and
she knows she is going to be tortured
and killed and she is not only resigned
to it she welcomes it she knew it was
gonna happen sooner or later and she's
ready and it's that sort of that weird
balance of I want to say villain she's
not really but she's not a good person
she's an awful person yet at the same
time having this weary acceptance of
their role in the world it's part it's
part of what I love about Gareth in
labyrinth I talked about that when I
talked about that movie and so you've
got all that going on and it managed to
also be touching and moving and
be really sad and and I can see because
I know this predates a lot of it I can
see where later episodes of Doctor Who
have borrowed elements from this story
I'm not gonna say ripped off because
some of the things I'm going to mention
took them and ran in either in
completely new directions or fleshed out
one specific aspect of this audio into
it and so that it's its own thing but if
things like the the this ultimately
proves to be a prison that just keeps
looping back around and around and
around or around where this guy has to
keep reliving and suffering through his
his crime over and over and over again
but the that the loop of that is
effectively the same thing the
confession dial was in Heaven Sent
so there's that you've got this this
child God murderous thing that keeps
asking are you my father which I can't
help but think are you my mommy you know
with with the the empty child but it's
more than just that superficial
connection because it also touches on
the way that children see their parents
in the case of the empty child you know
that child's need to find its mother and
how that overrides almost everything
else and this this for this child this
force because it's in the body of a
child is so destructive because it
doesn't have the moral compass yet to
understand and appreciate what it is
doing but it has to it needs to find its
mother now in this story in the Holy
Terror we've got this really mixed-up
thing where the where the child entity
thing seems to very much have an
awareness of what it's doing it seems to
revel in other's pain yet the lines are
delivered in a way that still retains
just a touch of that childlike innocence
where you really wonder does it truly
understand what
doing I mean it's obviously having fun
it says it wants to kill it takes
enjoyment out of that but you have to
wonder is any part of this just a
complete failure to understand because
it's too young to know what it is that
is going on but then towards the very
end there's a line I forget I forget the
exact wording but there's a line where
it's talking to Eugene who is ultimately
revealed to be the father of this thing
it's representative of his own child
that he killed and that's why he's in
this thing and has to keep reliving it
he's the one paying for the crime and it
says I worshipped you and that the the
moment that that got me that that choked
me up and and got a tear was when it
catches up to Eugene because it's been
hunting him basically through the last
segment of the story and you know you
geez like Eugene normally at this point
would be killing it again cuz that's
what he always does he kills it and it
goes away for a while and then it comes
in he rebuilds this world and then it
comes back and he he hesitates here and
he hesitates long enough that the the
creature comes to him and it doesn't
kill him it doesn't even say it wants to
kill him
it says I'm sorry and ask for
forgiveness the logic being I must have
done something so horrible that caused
you to kill me because that is the
thought process of a young child cos who
young child its parents are our gods the
hair supposed to fix everything they are
supposed to
you take care of everything they are the
end-all-be-all and when you're when
you're at a young age and you have to
trust them you have to have faith in
them and if they do something and you
know there must be a reason for it and
so to that young you know four or five
year old sense of logic my father killed
me
it must be because I did something awful
please forgive me and it's it's black
mirror levels of messed up and of
effective so that that really hit me
very hard so definitely with how
farcical this thing starts out the fact
that it ultimately hit me as emotionally
as it did by the time it was done was
astounding and along the way touching on
so many other things that I love like
the razor-sharp humor properly targeted
never punching down humor because again
even though it's using the framework of
religion really what it's talking about
it can be applied to any ritual any
ritual whether it is a religious ritual
a political ritual just a ritual in your
own home something just you and your
family you do why because it's what
you've always done you don't think about
it anymore
it's just poking at that behavior and
that and that feels at least to me
really clearly articulated throughout
the piece there's wonderful levels of
meta humor in this cuz Hilah I love
stories about stories and the power of
stories and the importance of stories
which this also is because you know
that's that's what's going on with
Eugene he keeps creating this world
basically so he doesn't have to think
about what he did in it and it holds his
attention until the rituals repeat so
many times that they lose their meaning
and it doesn't make sense anymore
and then
the child comes back again and destroys
it all and there is there's almost
nothing to criticize about this thing
it's actually it's actually really hard
to criticize because like some of the
stuff that you could criticize by the
time the story's over it becomes clear
these were actually features of the
narrative so like some of the characters
are really broadly sketched their arch
they are stereotypes as the doctor
himself says but then by the time you at
the end you realize oh that's by design
that's not a fault that's a feature so
it makes it really hard to criticize I
do have one I do have one criticism and
that is at the very end in terms of what
we learn what little we learn about why
Eugene killed his child we really don't
get much and I'm not saying like I
needed grisly details but what we get is
a line from him his child asks him why
and he says because I was mad and I'm
not mad as an angry mad as in crazy and
that's a cop-out to me it feels like it
feels it's too easy to just toss it off
as that as yeah it feels like something
that wasn't properly explored and it
feels like if it had been properly
explored it maybe could have been even
more unsettling than it was because I
feel like prior to that it had been
hinting at more than that there were
there were lines about you know how I'm
supposed to love my child that's normal
why can't I be normal I will love you
forever as long as you never come near
me and the thing is is there are times
that as a parent you've you have
thoughts or you have notions that make
you feel
wrong or awful even if it's for a split
second or maybe you feared having that I
know for me before my kid was born I you
know I was really worried because you
know all through the pregnancy I was I
was excited I was supportive of her
mother and everything but I wasn't
feeling like this direct connection to
this life yet um but after she was born
I did start to feel that and and that
was in many ways a huge relief because I
had read I had had a dreadful fear that
I was not gonna connect with my own kid
cuz on honestly I'm weird around kids
like I'm dumb really uncomfortable
around kids and that hasn't changed
having had my own I love my kid I like
to I'm pretty damn good with my kid but
I'm that that hasn't changed so you know
there was a fear of like am I gonna be
as weird around my own kid as I am
around other kids and I felt like this
story had the opportunity to to eat to
hit even harder by drilling into those
kinds of fears which I think are real
are those sorts of fleeting thoughts
that we have as parents you know if I
could just run away if I could just run
away like just for an hour
and you know which you know you have
that thought and it's an it's a normal
one that have but you you feel awful
afterwards and this becomes like that
times 10 or times a million really but
it it doesn't go there in the end it
just tosses it off as this implication
that he was he did something crazy and
that yeah like I said it feels like a
bit of a cop-out and that was a little
disappointing but that is literally the
only complaint that I have this story it
astounded me I'm yeah this was really
really good and the thing is I I don't
usually take a lot of notes when either
are white or something
or listen to something occasionally I do
like I did when I watched wargames cuz
that's because that's free and long and
that was multiple sessions for me to get
through but I kept scribbling down notes
for this you know elements and aspects
that I that I really liked lines that I
loved I never write down lines like you
but when I really can actually mean
maybe I'll remember it when it comes
time to do the review but I'm never like
I got a right back down
I'm multiple year and so now I'm
actually just gonna take another look at
my notes and see what I forgot to talk
about so I can tell you that's awesome
okay so children I kind of gloss over
him a little bit the the the extensive
villain for the opening chunk of it you
know the the the twisted sibling the
Richard the third kind of guy
the fact I love the fact that he doesn't
know he's basically a parody of a
mustache twirling villain and just that
moment that turnaround moment when he's
talking with his mother and he's like I
have resolved to be the village almost
quoting Shakespeare exactly and is well
just going yes but you never were evil
enough like again I love this mother god
what else was there
like the VI there's a great little
moment where FERPA sure and then the new
emperor are in front of the console and
you know the Apple calls it an altar and
Frobisher says no no it's a console and
the the Emperor he says well you say
that you stand there and it allows you
communication and means of travel to
other places and other realms well yeah
that my friend is an altar and just
finding ways around it or just just some
of these lines you're talking about
rituals of course they don't make any
sense otherwise they wouldn't have to be
rituals we just do them without a second
thought like that what an amazing line
that is or okay the mother talking with
with her son and and she's just she
talked about love and she says stay
perhaps you'll do the impossible and
teach me after all you know she was
ready to be dead because she figured she
was done she had no useless and maheno
use in the world anymore
like her her part in the story was done
and but she's had this notion that you
love me can you teach me how but not
like in a pleading way just in a maybe
you can like I don't think she had any
hope or faith that that would be the
case but it's possible we'll give it a
shot
like they just the the depths of all
this and then of course the doctor and
this circles background it doesn't
matter to whom the cruelty is directed
the cruelty itself is wrong and that not
only is that a great line that is a
wonderful sentiment and I think like
something a lot of us could stand to
really kind of have ingrained in our
heads as hard as as possible because I
think there's a lot of times a lot of us
will justify terrible behavior because
of who it's directed at like yes okay so
what I did wasn't great but it's okay
because this person was mean to me first
it's okay because I was in a really bad
mood it's okay because it was funny it's
okay because I fundamentally don't think
this person matters as much as I do you
know whatever the justification may be
but no matter how you painted cruelty is
cruelty and cruelty is wrong doesn't
matter who you do it to or it shouldn't
so yeah this was a really amazing listen
and I don't know what which big finish
I'm I'm gonna do neck yeah that's not
true I dunno because the the my patreon
supporters already selected for me but I
I do not envy the next one I have to
listen to because having to follow on
from this this is uh is a big shoes to
fill so that's the Holy Terror Big
Finish Wow have you heard it what you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's all the
stuff to do so just like isn't subscribe
I mentioned my page around a few times
for only $1 a month you too can
contribute ideas notions throw out
things that I might do can vote in polls
to help me decide which Big Finish story
to do next which classic whose story to
do next and and other things long as
nature helped me guide this channel to
be the best that it can be so there's
all that and Twitter and blah blah blah
blah blah links for all that is down in
the description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]